y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en directo américa de france 24
estoy con la llamada pitonisa animando a
daniela porque le digo pitonisa otra vez
después
prediciendo el futuro prediciendo el
futuro de anillo si raúl se lo diga no
se lo di me lo dijo y es que comienza a
enredarse este acuerdo de compra de
twitter no y el anuncio no podría hacer
por otro medio por twitter claro el
multimillonario y lo más publicó en su
cuenta personal un mensaje corto pero
bastante contundente dice el acuerdo de
twitter suspendido temporalmente a la
espera de detalles que respalden el
cálculo de que las cuentas falsas o spam
representan menos del 5 por ciento de
los usuarios esta es la estimación que
presentó la empresa en su más reciente
reporte financiero que da cuenta de que
tiene unos 229 millones de usuarios
diarios monetizables que quiere decir a
aquellos a los que efectivamente les
llega publicidad y el considerado hombre
más rico del mundo ha dicho justamente
que uno de sus objetivos o la compra de
twitter es
con los bots de spam de la plataforma
danny y es que este acuerdo también como
lo hemos venido comentando ha tenido
tropiezos desde el principio primero que
la financiación y varias cosas han
venido sucediendo este es apenas un
nuevo giro en el acuerdo de compra
planeado de la red social por 44 mil
millones de dólares el más reciente
había sido también el despido de dos de
los principales gerentes de la compañía
y la misma red social ha dicho que hay
varios riesgos como por ejemplo que los
anunciantes dejen de pautar en medio de
la incertidumbre que es la mejor palabra
para definir todo este acuerdo también
ha sido bastante polémico en los últimos
días el fundador de tesla ha venido
twitteando mensajes políticos entre
ellos uno en el que dice que donald
trump debería volver a la red social
entretanto le cuento raúl que el precio
de la acción llegó a desplomarse en
cerca del 18 por ciento en operaciones
previas a la comercialización oficial de
este viernes y adivine las de tesla su
buena razón o cosa que carrazos no dan y
cuando vamos a tener uno podemos comprar
uno entre los dos y nos venimos a
trabajar juntos
vamos a ir eeuu dani porque buscan
exportadores de fórmula para bebés claro
porque hay unas clases sin precedentes
de este producto en las estanterías y se
debe a varias razones le voy a enumerar
dos de ellas primero las continuas
interrupciones del suministro por el
hobbit 19 que hicieron que el inventario
se redujera y que se redujera todavía
más cuando los padres se sobre
abastecieron un fenómeno que se está
replicando ahora que la inflación está
disparada esto se ha combinado con el
reciente cierre de una fábrica de la
empresa a botón nutrición una de las más
grandes después de que cuatro bebés
sufrieran infecciones bacterianas tras
consumir esta leche y dos de ellos
murieran y es que la mayoría de este
producto contiene proteína de leche de
vaca que es alterada para que sea más
fácil de digerir y se agregan muchas
veces azúcares y aceite que están
haciendo las autorías entonces al
respecto para descubrir también las
necesidades de estos bebés que se
quedarían en un futuro pues y sin meses
sin sin leche sin su leche sin si no se
ponen las pilas
pues la situación ha tocado tal punto de
gravedad que el gobierno sugirió que se
usen las redes sociales inclusive para
intercambiar el producto y también está
explorando opciones como importar desde
méxico-chile países bajos e irlanda a
pesar de que eeuu produce el 98 por
ciento de lo que consume escuchamos el
presidente badén ordenó a la
administración que trabaje con urgencia
para garantizar que la fórmula infantil
sea segura y esté disponible para las
familias de todo el país durante el
retiro voluntario de abbott nutrition
este trabajo ha estado en marcha durante
meses el presidente baiden habló con
minoristas y fabricantes incluidos los
directores ejecutivos de wal mart y
target para instarlos a hacer más para
ayudar a las familias de todo el país a
comprar fórmula y el costo de la vida
han y sigue subiendo porque varios
países también se sumaron el aumento de
las tasas de interés raúl como hemos
venido comentando en las últimas semanas
hemos visto como países entre ellos eeuu
se han sumado al aumento de tasas de
interés esto como una manera de ponerle
freno al fenómeno de la inflación ahora
veamos unos más agresivos que otros pero
méxico y argentina se unieron el jueves
a otros de la región como colombia y
brasil que ya habían elevado sus tipos
de interés de esta manera entonces las
tasas de referencia de este grupo de
países oscilan entre el 5% que es perú y
el 49% en argentina donde rigen varios
tipos de interés y el incremento es
todavía mayor que en los otros países en
esta última nación los precios al
consumidor anotaron un incremento
interanual del 68 del 58% este es el más
alto en tres décadas danny que nos trae
hoy como cifra el día mide 200 mil
millones de dólares se estima que
perdieron en un solo día los mercados de
las cripto monedas según el medio
especializado siguen vice que reporta
que el bitcoin que es la más popular
cayó por debajo de los 26 mil dólares
por primera vez en 16 meses y es que la
inflación en la subida de tasas y los
temores sobre el crecimiento económico
han ayudado a este resultado hoy se le
va a poner fácil como dice la canción de
dónde vengo yo de venezuel bueno y nos
vamos a venezuela porque ahí está lista
nuestra corresponsal para hablar de lo
que va a pasar este lunes también
precisamente en materia económica lo que
hablamos ayer sin saber que es otro sí
claro que sí vamos a venezuela de una
vez